plus de quatre mois après l'annoncé d'un
accord commercial sur le break site
ce dernier va peut-être enfin entrer en
vigueur les députés européens devraient
se prononcer ce mardi sur le traité
conclu le 24 décembre dernier une
délibération tardive qui vise à
protester contre l'attitude de londres à
propos de l'épineux dossier de l'irlande
du nord
boris johnson refuse le retour d'une
barrière commerciale intégral entre la
province britannique et la grande
bretagne
une disposition pourtant prévu dans
l'accord si l'union européenne semble
trop dogmatique et qu'on continue à être
dans cette situation absurde où on ne
peut pas importer des buissons de rose
avec de la terre britannique en irlande
du nord où des saucisses britannique en
irlande du nord
alors franchement je prendrait de
nouvelles mesures une décision
unilatérale sur les contrôles prise par
londres sans en avertir bruxelles ce qui
a causé la colère des dirigeants
européens qu'ils réaffirment leur
volonté de suivre le protocole établi
dans l'accord commercial tous les
progrès dans les relations entre londres
et bruxelles pourraient être perdus si
le royaume uni continuent à violer
unilatéralement l'accord c'est la
seconde fois que le gouvernement
britannique s'apprête à enfreindre le
droit international
une question explosive pour la province
britannique qui a connu plusieurs nuits
d'émeute ces dernières semaines entre
loyalistes pro britanniques partisans
d'un statu quo et nationaliste qui
souhaitent l'unification des deux
irlande une agitation qui ravive les
douloureux souvenirs de la guerre civile
qui a eu lieu dans la région pendant la
seconde moitié du xxème siècle une
résurgence des troubles que souhaite
éviter à tout prix
londres et bruxelles